- Good morning and welcome
to Radcliffe day 2017.
And welcome to a lovely
spring day in New England.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
I'm a professor of American
history here at Harvard,
and, like many of you, I am
an avid and concerned consumer
of the news.
I am also a longtime admirer of
Gwen Ifill and Judy Woodruff,
whom we will honor
with Radcliffe's metals
at today's lunch.
By tradition, and by
design, this morning panel
is devoted to a topic
that is close to the heads
and hearts of our honorees,
often highlighting challenges
in the area in which
they have excelled.
Today's exploration, of
untruths and their consequences,
will help us appreciate Gwen and
Judy's commitment to integrity
in journalism all the more.
Over a year ago, we decided
to focus this Radcliffe day
on the changing media
landscape and to celebrate
the best of journalism.
When we began planning, the
phrase, alternative facts,
was still an oxymoron and not
yet a fact of our existence,
fake news was a
fringe phenomenon,
and the Oxford English
Dictionary had not yet
designated post-truth as its
word of the year for 2016.
Who, then, could imagine a
president of the United States
accusing the mainstream
media of purveying fake news,
and in a tweet,
calling the free press,
the enemy of the
American people?
Presidents have long been
annoyed, even angered,
by journalists,
but they have not
depicted freedom of
the press as a threat
to the very nation
that enshrines
that ideal in its constitution.
Meanwhile, we are experiencing
equally dramatic changes
in the ways that we
encounter the news.
A proliferation
of media sources,
including Facebook, clickbait,
tweets, retweets, and memes,
has infiltrated
the news landscape.
The dizzying number
and speed of new media
challenge the
notion of authority,
dismantle long standing
methods of quality control,
and fragment American
audiences into narrow,
and often ideologically
defined, market segments.
Tried and true media
like television news,
frequently use similar
divide and conquer tactics.
Networks know that there are
large potential audiences
on the left, and the right, and
across all educational levels
and income brackets, who want
their biases confirmed, not
challenged, by uncomfortable
or inconvenient facts.
So, instead of sober and
meticulous reporting,
we see panels of partisans who
substitute loudness of shouting
for depth of analysis.
Simplified messages might
entertain viewers and boost
ratings, but they do not
provide the illuminating inquiry
that an informed
electorate requires.
And, yet, with
all the pandering,
a large proportion of
the American public
still claims to deeply distrust
the media and the information
it conveys.
That distrust
should worry us all.
Whether the topic is
the fate of Obamacare,
relations with Russia,
or climate change,
only a well informed citizenry,
with a genuine understanding
of the issues at stake,
can weigh opposing views
and make smart and
fair decisions,
with full appreciation of
the trade offs involved.
A healthy, trusted
news media matters
to all of us who care
about making the United
States the robust, deliberative
democracy it has long
aspired to be.
How can we hope to live
up to those aspirations
with an embattled first
amendment, a besieged media,
and an electorate
wandering in the wilderness
unable to distinguish
between truth and untruths?
We are here today to probe
how we got here, but perhaps
even more important, to ask
what we can do about it.
We should also ask how
journalism and journalists can
respond to these challenges.
I am cheered, for
example, that in the face
of the turmoil of the last
four months, and particularly
over the astonishing
last few weeks,
there have been journalists
who have remained undeterred,
and even more determined,
to fulfill the press's
constitutional responsibility
to pursue the truth wherever
it may take us.
One of the ways that we tackle
big questions like these
at the Radcliffe
Institute is by assembling
stellar groups of individuals
to share experiences
and expertise.
We do so, all year long,
with lectures, conferences,
and seminars, and
today is no exception.
As an Institute
for advanced study,
we know that deep research and
informed analysis do matter,
and we value debate among
different perspectives as a way
to move deliberation forward.
This morning's discussion
brings together
some of today's best minds.
Liberal, and conservative, from
the classroom, and the news
room, to help us
think through an issue
that surely stands among the
most important challenges
our society faces
at this moment.
To guide our
conversation today, we
are fortunate to have my Harvard
colleague, Ann Marie Lipinski,
as our moderator.
Ann Marie has won a Pulitzer
for her own investigative
journalism, and has gone
on to award Pulitzers
to others, first as
a member, and then
as co-chair of the
Pulitzer Prize board.
Ann Marie is
currently the curator
of the Nieman
Foundation at Harvard,
and in her six
years on campus, she
has made the Nieman
program an integral part
of Harvard's academic life.
In planning this
year's Radcliffe day
on the topic of
integrity and journalism,
I have benefited enormously
from Ann Marie's insight
and her generosity.
She has been with me
every step of the way,
so I am delighted to
have her here today
to introduce our panelists and
to moderate the discussion.
But, before we dive into
our panel discussion,
we have a special treat.
As you know, this
afternoon we will honor
Gwen Ifill and Judy Woodruff.
Someone who has worked
closely with both of them
is David Brooks, columnist
at the New York Times,
and frequent guest
on the PBS NewsHour.
Whatever the
medium, David always
enlightens us with
his own unique angle
on concerns of the moment.
David has to be in
Washington, DC this afternoon.
He's actually going to hold
the fort at the PBS NewsHour,
so he will not be able to
stay for the lunch program.
But he did not
want this day to go
by without adding his own
tribute to Gwen and to Judy.
So when David finishes
his reflections,
Ann Marie will
introduce the panelists
and we will begin
our discussion.
Please join me now in
welcoming David to the podium.
- Thank you.
I thought I'd try to impress
my boss by showing up
to work today.
Now, you should know, I teach
at Yale, and so I'll be brief.
I know you Harvard people didn't
come here to hear me speak,
you came here to hear
yourselves speak.
I will try to get out
of the way of that.
I have a unique specialty.
I go on Public Broadcasting
and I debate Catholics
from Massachusetts.
One of them on
NPR, is EJ Dionne,
is sitting over there somewhere.
And then, I do a segment on
the NewsHour with Mark Shields,
our segment is called
Shields and Brooks.
It should've been
called Brook Shields,
but that wouldn't
have been better.
My line about Mark,
is, he's been doing it
for a little while,
that's the segment's now
Shields and Brooks.
Before that, it was Shields
and [? Shego, ?] before
that, it was Shields and
Gergen and before that it was
Shields and Coolidge, I think.
It started out at Shields
and Thomas Aquinas,
I think, it's a while ago.
And we do have just
a very good time.
The show always
lightens my spirit,
and informs me, and makes
me feel a little better
about America,
because of that show.
Our audience skews a
little on the senior side.
When a 93-year-old lady comes
up to me in the airport,
I know what she's going to say,
it's I don't watch your show
but my mother loves it.
So I'll just give a few quick
remarks about Gwen and Judy.
I have a group that I have
dinner with every Thursday
night in DC.
I've written a
column about them.
And they're a bunch
of kids from DC,
almost all African-American
kids 18 to 22,
and they've had
rough backgrounds.
And they all come to this
home where they can stay
and where they get food.
And we meet there
every Thursday,
and we've been doing it
for about three years.
And they're just on
the cusp of life.
And what we give
them is, we adults
sit there and let them
show their talents to us
and find themselves in that way.
We provide them for an audience.
What they give to us is
a complete intolerance
of social distance.
So I walk into this thing
the first time I went there
three years ago and I met
a kid and his name was Ed
and I reached out
to shake his hand,
and he just said, we don't
really shake hands here,
we hug here, and he sort
of embraced me in a hug
and we've been hanging all
over each other ever since.
And so, I was there last
night, with these kids,
and it was just such a pleasure
to use time over dinner
to talk about Gwen
and Judy and to tell,
sort of that generation,
a few things about how
one can conduct one's life.
And when I agreed to do this,
I thought Gwen would be here,
and I was going to give
her a lot more crap
than I'll be able to today.
But one of the things
I described to them
was that on the day
Gwen died and Judy
called with the news I
went through my emails,
and I just looked at all
the emails she'd sent me.
And some of them were
just check in emails,
how you doin', you know, or
giving me some business about
a column I'd written.
But a surprising number
were surprisingly tough
like, you need to learn
to communicate better,
or, there were things that
I had let down the show.
And her toughness
is one of the things
that that leaps out at me.
Toughness and tenacity.
A tenacity we saw all
through the conventions,
as she continued doing her
work, when she was much sicker
than I, at least, knew.
And so, she's at the end of
the spectrum on toughness
and resilience, but
she's also on the end
of the spectrum on kindness.
And it's that odd combination
of those two things,
extremely incandescent around
people at the same time
toughness on behalf of craft.
The love of people
is at the extreme,
the dedication to craft,
the humility before God.
And so the thing I
wanted to talk to my kids
about was, just what it is,
is a vocation, which, I think,
if there's one thing that
Judy and Gwen represent,
it's that quality of
having a vocation,
and dedication to vocation.
Frederick Bittner,
the novelist, once
wrote that a vocation is
where your deep gladness meets
the world's deepest need and
it's the marriage of those two
things.
A career is something
you choose and you
do as long as it's paying
off for you, but a vocation
you're sort of summoned to.
The great example is, Viktor
Frankl was a psychologist
in Austria in the '30s.
He was put in Auschwitz,
and he said, you know,
we often tell people, what
do you want from life,
and he said that's
the wrong question.
The right question is,
what is life asking of you.
And I would say
for Gwen and Judy,
life, and especially this
year, has asked them,
and asked Judy now, to be
an anchor of a certain sort
of news organization, which
I'll describe in a minute
but which is a certain
sort of old fashioned news
organization.
A vocation requires a talent,
which Gwen and Judy have had.
It reveals itself
through a pleasure.
When you found your vocation
you get intrinsic pleasure out
of doing those things,
and most of all
it expresses itself
through a consistency
of commitment over time.
A commitment is falling
in love with something
and then building a structure
of behavior around it
for those moments
when love falters.
And so, when I think
about the NewsHour
and especially Gwen's commitment
to it and now Judy's, what
I think about is consistency
over time and permanence.
When I think of Judy, I
think of her writing notes
furiously before a segment,
through the afternoon
and through the mornings.
Judy's been in this
business a while
and it would be easy to coast.
Television is an
industry in which
coasting is supremely easy
and supremely alluring.
And yet I've never seen her
come anything less than 300%
prepared for any segment
we've been doing.
And so, it is that
consistency and permanence
over time that I think
is what's so emblematic,
and that's what I so much
wanted to talk to my kids about.
And then permanence and
consistency in what we do.
The NewsHour is
not just a program,
it's an institution, and those
of us who come to work there,
it was there before
we came, and I hope
and pray it will be there
long after we're gone.
And when you come
to the NewsHour,
you come and try to inhabit
certain standards of behavior.
For the first 10 years I did
it, the host was Jim Lehrer,
and when I would say
something good on the program,
his eyes would crinkle
with a little pleasure,
and when I said something
bad his mouth would turn down
in a little displeasure.
And so, I learned how
to do this business
by trying to avoid the mouth
turn down and get the eye
crinkle.
And so, there's certain
standards that no one even
has to express, that
are inherent in walking
in the place.
And Jim and Robbins
started it, Gwen and Judy
have continued it, and I
think we all have a sensation
now that somehow
the NewsHour has
found its moment in this year.
Not only in the
ratings, which we
don't care about, but
in the value of doing
the permanent, long-standing
traditional things in an era
where impermanence
and attention-deficit
are becoming the norm.
And so, something stable,
and solid, and permanent,
and old-fashioned,
and counter-cultural,
somehow becomes a pillar in a
moment when a lot of pillars
are being washed away.
And so, basically, I just
talked to the kids about all
these things, about
permanence, about institutions,
about vocations, about
the love of people,
and then just to round it
off I took out my phone
and I took out a big
picture of Gwen on my phone.
And after Gwen died when people
were eulogizing her the one
thing every eulogy
and every obituary
had was about the
quality of her smile.
And the words were,
incandescent, luminescent,
lit from within.
And I don't know what creates
that kind of incandescence
and luminescence, but taking
pleasure in the small things
and in the people, combined
with that ferocious dedication
to the integrity of craft
was what marked her,
and which marks
the program today,
which I think a lot of us are so
proud to be in the same country
with.
Thank you.
- Many, many thanks to David
Brooks for those comments,
and also for the work that
he, and Judy, and, Gwen,
have so thoughtfully
done, for so long,
on the NewsHour I think you'd
all agree that, together, they
offered us some of the
smartest political analysis
of the recent election season
and post election season
and I am abundantly grateful
for him and for that.
OK, enough about
the guy from Yale.
I am so honored
to be here today,
and especially want to thank
Dean Cohen for including me
in this very, very
important conversation,
and also to thank her
for her prescience.
If anything, her notion
to honor Judy and Gwen
and explore the
theme of untruths
and their consequences, is
more urgent, and relevant,
and smarter today, than when she
first broached it a year ago,
so we all owe her
a lot of gratitude
for even conceiving
of this idea.
It seemed like an
issue at the time
but, boy, is it an issue now.
So thank you so much for that.
And as President Faust very
recently reminded our Fellows
at the Nieman Foundation
for Journalism
in a so-called
post-truth environment,
the issues bearing on
the media are precisely
those faced by the academy
certainly here at Harvard,
where the motto is veritas.
So, I think that what we'll
be dealing with today,
both celebrating,
and concerned about,
has such direct ties to
what we do here every day.
It is no exaggeration to say
that, for many in my industry,
Gwen and Judy are heroes.
Two women who join forces
to create a, sort of,
journalistic true north.
Through their work
individually, and together, they
have not only personified
our highest values,
but defined them.
In what has been a
remarkably challenging year,
the NewsHour has
offered us everything we
ask of journalism done right.
On a personal note, I would also
like to publicly acknowledge
my great debt to Gwen who is
on the search committee that
brought me to Harvard, so
I am very grateful to her.
We are so privileged to have
four extraordinary panelists
with us, this morning,
to try and help
us make sense of this
interesting and complicated
time.
They offer a diversity
of experience,
and perspective,
which we will hear
reflected in their remarks.
A little bit about format, I
will do brief introductions
of them all next, and then
we'll hear from each of them
to make some brief
opening comments,
and then we will
convene a conversation
about these issues, and,
also, invite questions
from the audience, which
somewhere there are
pieces of paper going around.
Cards, and you can submit those
to people gathering those,
and we will try to
integrate as many of those
as we can into the conversation.
So, first is Danielle Allen,
director of Harvard's Edmond J.
Safra Center for Ethics and
a political theorist who
has published broadly
on democratic theory
and the history of
political thought.
Danielle's books
include a recent
and widely read re-examination
of the Declaration
of Independence, and she is
also a contributing columnist
to The Washington Post,
where she wrote regularly
about the election.
Jonah Goldberg is the senior
editor of the National Review
and author of a broadly
published syndicated
column, weekly columnist
for the Los Angeles Times,
and contributor to USA
Today, and to Fox News.
He is the author
of Liberal Fascism:
the Secret History
of the American Left,
and The Tyranny of
Cliches: How Liberals
Cheat in the War of Ideas.
A'Lelia Bundles is a
journalist and author
working on her fourth
book, a biography
of her great-grandmother.
She served as a news
executive at both NBC and ABC,
including as the deputy
bureau chief in Washington.
She chairs the board of the
National Archives Foundation
and serves on the
Schlesinger Library Council
here at the Radcliffe Institute.
And EJ Dionne who is a columnist
for The Washington Post,
and a senior Fellow at
the Brookings Institute.
He appears regularly
on ABC's This Week,
on MSNBC, and, of course,
on National Public Radio,
where we hear him frequently
in debate with David Brooks.
You get the last word today, EJ.
- For once!
- He is the author of
six books, including,
Why the Right Went Wrong,
Conservatism from Goldwater
to the Tea Party and Beyond.
We will start with Danielle.
- Thank you Ann Marie.
Good morning.
You can do better than that!
Good morning!
Thank you.
It is such an honor to be here
in celebration of Gwen Ifill
and to be here with my
distinguished fellow panelists.
And I was worried about
being cold out here,
but I already have begun to feel
the warmth in David's remarks,
and in the assembly
of people here,
so it's a pleasure
to be with you.
I did, as Ann Marie said,
spend much of last year
working as a columnist
for The Washington Post
writing about the
election, thinking
about the American
people, and thinking
about what's becoming of us.
But the truth of the matter is
that I am a historian first.
And so, in moments of
complexity and difficulty
the first thing I do is
look at historical examples
to try to contextualize.
This is not the first
difficult moment
this country has lived
through, by any stretch
of the imagination.
We could spend any
number of hours talking
about the Civil War,
the most extreme example
of our difficulty.
But we don't need to look
that far back, of course.
You'll hear some about
Watergate, this morning,
from some of my
fellow panelists.
And I want to go back just a
little bit before the hardest
part of McCarthyism, the late
1930s, when Father Coughlin's
radio show was sweeping
up millions of listeners.
Initially, he focused on a
sort of pro-Roosevelt agenda,
but he turned at a certain
point to being, in effect,
an advocate for
Hitler, and producing
a lot of anti-Semitic
radio broadcasts,
and was seen as, generally,
in a dangerous way,
spurring problematic populism.
He was a supporter of
Huey Long, for instance.
So, there is an organization
that sprang up in 1937,
funded by Filene, of Filene's
basement department stores,
called the Institute
of Propaganda Analysis.
And this was an organization
that was, in some sense,
trying to answer exactly
the question we're all
here today trying to answer,
what do you do with fake news.
What do you do when people
are swayed by fictions,
by lies, and so forth.
And they worked for five
years developing lessons,
disseminating them in
schools, teaching people
how to identify the
marks of propaganda.
So, they have a list of
items that they asked people
to pay attention to.
But I wanted to share
a little bit more
about some of the specifics
of what they are trying to do,
because I think it could
be helpful for ourselves,
as we try to think our
way through this moment.
So, first of all, I just
wanted to share with you
their analysis of the challenge
of the media in their day
and age.
It sounds very similar to
the kinds of complaints
that we have.
They're concerned about the
common man being swept up,
having all kinds of anxiety
because of The Depression,
of course, and the combination
of changes in the agricultural,
and rural areas,
and urban areas.
And then they're
worried about the people
who are able to take
advantage of this anxiety.
And they wrote, "As a rule,
spokesmen for these groups
are not concerned
with the ethics
of the means by which they use
to get the common man to make
up his mind.
They're concerned
only with getting
him to make up his mind
in unquestioning agreement
with them.
And to get him to do this they
employ all the subtleties,
all the knowledge
of human psychology,
which is the modern
world's heritage.
Their persuasive
appeals are geared
to the century's streamlined
channels of communication,
the newspaper, the radio, the
motion picture, sky writing,
blazing neon in electric signs,
and innumerable other media."
In other words, skywriting
was their Twitter.
So that's how we may sound
50 years from now, in regard
to the hysteria and
some sense that we often
express about the media.
So the problem is
not necessarily
the channels of communication,
it's something else.
From their point of
view, the problem
was specifically
whether or not we
were cultivating
critical intelligence,
as educators, and as a nation.
And so they built a series of
programs that had two purposes.
One was to re-engage
adults in what
they called free discussion.
To return to communal
conversation,
rather than mass communication,
as a way of trying
to revive independent thinking,
or, as they called it,
the free play of intelligence.
The second thing they did was to
focus on the scientific method
and here's where I think they
got something right, but also
something wrong.
So they wrote, as
one of their goals
that they wanted to
achieve, an understanding
and a working knowledge
of the scientific method.
Through day to day
individual and group
practice in asking
such questions as,
are our premises
supported by the evidence,
and do our conclusions
follow from our premises?
They focus a lot on facts.
On getting people to clean
up their use of facts,
and they used the techniques
of the scientific method
to support this.
And so, for example,
just to give you
one more quotation about
their focus on facts,
they said this,
about their goal,
"education, the
development of the ability
to make judgments
independently, has
its roots in the gathering
and classification
of pertinent facts, bearing
upon the problem or question,
and the arranging and organizing
of these facts in order
that a tentative solution
may be suggested."
So facts, facts, facts.
And they're right,
we need to do work
on re-educating people
in the scientific method
and the use of evidence,
especially young people.
But where are values
in that formulation?
My own view is that a lot of the
difficulties we currently face
have to do with our
inability to talk
about some core American
and shared values.
There are two that I
believe are married
to each other fundamentally,
liberty and equality.
And from my point of
view, conservatives
don't do a good job
talking about equality,
and liberals do a terrible
job talking about freedom.
And so, as we work on
cleaning up our facts,
I believe we also need to work
on cleaning up our capacity
to think about the abstract
ideals that, in fact, give
democracy its meaning.
If you ask somebody
what a monarchy is,
you point to the
picture of a King.
You ask somebody
what a democracy is,
there's no picture to point to.
There's what we do together,
through conversation,
in order to make liberty
and equality real.
Now, what on earth
does that mean?
We have to rebuild our
understanding of that, which
I think we can do
only conversationally,
and I think that's as
important as the work we
need to do on facts.
Thank you.
- Thank you Danielle.
Jonah?
- First of all, I know we got
a really crammed schedule,
but I want to say
what a real honor
and treat it is
for me to be here,
and it's a wonderful event, but
I also only have a few minutes
so, as Henry the Eighth
said to each of his wives,
I won't keep you long.
Where to begin?
Yes, I'm a journalist, but
I should make it very clear,
I'm a conservative
opinion journalist who
works for a magazine
called National Review,
and we've always seen
ourselves, in the tradition
of Bill Buckley, as
it's trying to be
the policemen of the right.
Sometimes we don't do
it as well as we should,
and sometimes we certainly don't
do it the way people like EJ
would like us to do it, but
we take the mission seriously.
And one of the most
disappointing and painful
things of these last
two years for me--
I've spent my time
on Amazon searching
for deals on Hemlock--
is the degree to
which I've heard
from enormous numbers of people,
longtime fans of my writing,
or of National Review,
who are disappointed
in me that I didn't live
down to their expectations.
And by that, I mean,
I could not bring
myself to support Donald
Trump in the primaries
or in the general election,
and the basic argument I made,
is that the conservatism I
love, that I grew up with--
and I've been doing this
for a very long time,
I literally met Pat
Buchanan at my bris--
boils down to just simply--
and I think that actually
explains some of Pat's views
on the Jews, too, these
people are barbarians!
Anyway.
Conservatism has
lots of definitions,
and I can quote lots of them,
but at the end of the day,
at the meta level, it boils
down to just two things,
the idea that character matters,
and the idea that ideas matter.
And you can have big
debates about what
you mean by character,
how you should
define character, what's
good character, what's
bad character.
And you can have a big argument
about what ideas matter,
but that's it.
And when I say ideas
matter, and I very much
agree with Danielle
about this, that it's
about the importance
of argument,
about reason, about marshaling
facts and logic to your side
to make an argument, because
that's what democracy is about.
It's about arguments.
Democracy is not
about agreement.
Democracy is about
disagreement, and the ability
to voice disagreement at
both at the polling station
but also in the public realm.
And my problem with
Donald Trump was always
that he stands to thwart
both the importance of ideas,
which occasionally he walks
through their zip code.
And I've yet, after two years
now, of asking this question,
I've asked people to
come up with a definition
of good character
that he can meet.
And it doesn't have to be about
sexuality or any of that stuff.
It could be about business
practices, or honesty,
or self-restraint.
If you pick up any definition
you want, I'm open to,
no one's been able
to make the case.
And so, therefore,
this gets to the point
of why I think it's really
important in journalism.
I actually believe
that opinion journalism
is among the best
forms of journalism,
because opinion journalism
you are actually
making an argument.
It's very much like
advocates in a court of law.
We all know that the prosecution
is biased towards conviction,
and we all know that the
defense attorney is biased
towards acquittal, but there
are certain rules of the court
that you have to deal with.
You have to deal
with the facts, you
have to address the other side's
best arguments, not their worst
ones, or you'll lose, and
you have to tell the truth.
And that's how I think
democracy advances is
by making those arguments.
And one of the reasons why I
love opinion journalism is you
get to tell the reader
where you're coming from,
and you say this is what this
is the argument I want to make,
yeah I'm a conservative,
or I'm a liberal,
it doesn't really matter, but
this is where I'm coming from
and you can always tell the
best opinion journalism,
whether it's on the right or
the left in The New Yorker,
or The Nation, or the National
Review, The Weekly Standard,
by how well the writer
characterizes the other side's
best arguments.
And, I think, that is
where an enormous amount
of important work for democracy
is done, through journalism,
is there.
Reporting is all
great, and important,
and I'm not trying
to diminish it,
but where a democracy
has its arguments
is through opinion
journalism, through the higher
end of opinion journalism.
Not the barking shout shows
on late night cable news
or any of that kind of stuff.
And so now I should
very quickly note
that there are a lot of
people out there, many
I suspect might be in this
room, who, sort of, walked
into the movie of American
politics, and seen Donald Trump
and yelled, where did
this monster come from,
and they act as if they've
walked into the last five
minutes of the movie.
This stuff has been building
for a very long time.
The idea that mainstream
media, the Democratic Party,
the liberals are utterly
blameless in the problems that
have arisen may be very
reassuring to certain people,
but you're not going to get
to the heart of the problem
unless you address it.
And the mainstream media
did not lose its credibility
during the Republican primaries.
The mainstream media did
not lose half the country,
essentially, because Donald
Trump persuaded them to.
Donald Trump took advantage
and exploited that.
Donald Trump is sort
of a classic populist.
One of my favorite lines comes
from William Jennings Bryan,
where he says, the people of
Nebraska are for free silver,
therefore I am for free silver,
I will look up the arguments
later.
And, again, as a
conservative who
believes in the importance
of ideas and arguments,
I actually believe you should
make the case for free silver,
if you actually believe
the case for free silver.
And one of the things
that has driven me crazy
is how many of my
colleagues on the right
think that they have
to speak for their base
rather than speak what
they believe to be true.
It is astounding to
me how many times
when the little light on the
top of the camera goes off,
people who have been defending
Donald Trump will turn to me
and say, I can't believe
I have to defend this guy.
And I think about 90%
of journalistic ethics
is a bunch of self-indulgent
guild mentality.
But one of the things I actually
truly and passionately believe
in, and I think it solves most
journalistic ethical problems,
is don't lie.
If you believe
something isn't true,
you shouldn't say, or
write, that it's true.
It's not the most complicated
thing in the world.
So what I've some dismay
about the Trumpian moment
is how corrupting it
has been to the right
where it seems fairly obvious
that you should condemn someone
for beating up a journalist
for asking about a CBO score.
And, yet, yesterday, Twitter
and all sorts of other places
lit up with defenses of this.
That this reporter
asked for it, and I
can't get my head around it and
I find it utterly dismaying.
But I should also-- anyway, to
get back to the point at hand,
the credibility of
the mainstream media--
we hear a lot about fake news,
and we're going to talk a lot
about fake news, But you guys
do realize that Jon Stewart ran
a TV show called The Daily
Show, which was lionized across
the mainstream media, won
a Peabody Award for its
journalism, was the number one
source of news for millennials
throughout the last decade,
and it is literally--
not figuratively, the way
Joe Biden uses literally--
literally a fake news program.
And there wasn't a lot of
outrage or embarrassment
about it.
I think, in part, cause it
was really funny and very
well produced.
But there have been
a lot of things
that have undermined the
credibility of the mainstream
media for a very long
time with a lot of people
who don't necessarily agree
with a lot of its assumptions.
And to, all of a sudden,
walk into the situation
that we're in now, by all means
use Donald Trump as a pinata,
but he's not the author
of any of these problems,
he's a symptom of them.
And I'll just close by saying,
we live in an idiot culture.
And what I mean by culture
is not we're all morons,
although they're
well-represented at large.
Idiot comes from
the ancient Greek
and it means someone who didn't
have sufficient knowledge
to be a good citizen.
The words idiosyncratic,
and all the other words
that have the same
root, meant someone
who is alienated and
deracinated, or disconnected,
from the greater good and
from the public polity,
and that they didn't have
the wherewithal or knowledge
to be a good citizen.
And this is a problem we
have in our society that
has nothing to do with
right wing versus left wing.
It has to do with how
we're raising people.
It has to do with the kind of
citizens that we're producing.
The original idea
of the liberal arts
wasn't an idea about
making people liberal,
it was about giving people
the tools, and requirements,
and sets of knowledge to
make them good citizens,
and this country is
falling down on that job.
NewsHour is a fantastic
program, but it's very difficult
to sustain something like
that when there isn't a market
for it, and we have to figure
out how to better train young
people to want good news
and good journalism,
because as it stands right
now, a lot of them don't.
Thank you all very much.
- Thank you, Jonah.
A'Lelia?
- Thank you, Ann Marie.
I was so honored last summer
when Liz Cohen sent me a note
and said that Gwen had asked
that I be on the panel,
and that's because Gwen knew
how much I love Radcliffe,
and I'm class of '74, and
one of the last presidents
of the Radcliffe College
Alumni Association.
So, Gwen and I, our
paths didn't cross
when we overlapped for a year,
as part of that first big post
1968, post Martin Luther
King, Jr. assassination
and long overdue Initiative
to recruit black students
to New England colleges
and prep schools.
But our lives
eventually intersected
in many concentric circles
through mutual friends,
through journalism, and
like many black reporters,
Jesse Jackson's 1984 campaign.
What I hope I can bring
to today's conversation
is a sense of the constancy
and consistency and depth
of Gwen's integrity.
She remained solid, grounded,
decent, and generous,
whether she was
moderating a town hall,
or sitting on her back
porch with her girlfriends.
I believe that
journalists earn trust
by the way we live our lives.
The same goes for
elected officials.
At our best, we live by the
adage, comfort the afflicted,
and afflict the comfortable.
As a reporter,
Gwen kept her tools
sharpened, curiosity,
skepticism,
but never cynicism, accuracy,
respect for others, empathy
for those who felt
misunderstood,
encouragement for the
young people she mentored,
impatience with those who
did less than their best,
and no mercy for those
who lied and made excuses.
She was unimpressed
by shiny things.
In a story too long to
tell, this morning, I
remember when she
was being recruited
by another network for a
show with higher visibility
and I assume
substantially more money
than she was making
at the NewsHour.
But after much to-ing and
fro-ing, she withdrew her name.
She chose substance
over shininess.
She knew she would be
judged and measured,
just as all television
reporters and anchors are
judged and measured,
and expected
to be the shiny new thing
who could rescue the ratings.
But, over time, she had been
intentional about developing
a pact with her audience, to
be authentic, to shed light,
rather than to generate heat.
I think she sensed that
this path she had developed
would have less currency
in the new environment.
And, yet, to see her on
the Sunday morning shows,
on Meet the Press, and this
week in Face the Nation,
was a joy to behold.
She always brought her A-game.
There was no question that
she was equal to the task.
Gwen's annual New Year's
Day party was legendary,
and, in many ways, a
metaphor for her life.
Her capacity for love, and
friendship, and collegiality,
was expansive and encompassing.
Some years later,
after the first set
of parties when she
moved to a new house,
which looked a lot like
the old house on steroids.
Bigger with the same floor plan.
It seemed as if she had done
so to accommodate the expanding
circle of friends and
colleagues and ideas
At the end of the
party, I have to admit,
I was always one
of the stragglers.
One of the extended
circle of girlfriends who
gathered in the living room.
Gwen was our friend
whom Queen Latifah had
played on Saturday Night Live.
Our champion who had stumped
Dick Cheney and John Edwards
on a question they should
have been able to answer.
But Gwen was Gwen,
always, always.
Gwen never became
an anchor monster,
the term some of us who
spend our lives as producers
use for people who
scream and throw
tantrums when the red light
on the camera goes off.
In 2017, it should not
be necessary to say
that a social gathering
like Gwen's annual party
was remarkable and
unusual in its diversity.
In 2017, it should
not be noteworthy,
that a social gathering with
people of different races,
ethnicities, backgrounds,
beliefs, party affiliations,
and ideologies, is a rarity.
But people whose paths
crossed at Gwen's would not
have met each
other, but for her.
In a politically polarized
nation, that matters.
The sensibilities she developed
as a preacher's kid who often
was the new face, as the
daughter of immigrants,
as a black girl in
mostly white settings,
as a political reporter when
the bus was mostly boys,
found their way into her work
as the host of Washington
Week and every job she held.
There's so much more I want
to say but time is short.
There is not enough
time to talk about how
Gwen handled bigotry,
and racism, and straight
up ignorance, with grace.
How she deflected and
smacked down the trolls
who found her on Twitter.
When we talk about untruths and
consequences, as we are today,
I think one could
argue that a failure
on the part of journalists,
news executives, publishers,
elected officials, and
people who knew better,
to more forcefully confront
the lies about Barack Obama's
birthplace and
birth certificate,
changed the course of history.
The brand of lies
that we are hearing
now and the liars who purvey
them are immune to our outrage.
We have crossed the threshold
when public figures lie
with the confidence
that it does not
matter that the lie
can be exposed right
after the commercial break, When
the file footage is queued up.
But there is a glimmer of hope.
Liars get cocky.
Liars miscalculate.
Lies backfire.
Lies have unintended
consequences.
As Abraham Lincoln said, you
can fool all of the people some
of the time, and some of
the people all of the time,
but you cannot fool all of
the people all of the time.
Though, I will concede that,
in a nation where we still
are debating the causes and
consequences of the Civil War,
one can take nothing for granted
and must be ever vigilant.
But we owe it to Gwen
to keep insisting.
On the truth I leave
you with Gwen's words,
we can't expect the world
to get better by itself,
we have to create something we
can leave the next generation.
And with love and respect
for my friend Gwen
I say that when we hear a
lie we must challenge it.
- Thank you, A'Lelia.
EJ, you're up.
- The definition of
life being unfair
is to have to speak after
all these eloquent people.
I want to pay tribute
to three people.
One is Drew Faust who's sitting
in the audience in front of us,
who was generous enough to
leave the perfect job, which
was starting and running
the Radcliffe Institute,
to lead this great
university, and if drew
doesn't mind my invoking
Richard Nixon's slogan,
we need your intellectual
leadership now more than ever.
So, thank you.
Also, all the tributes to Gwen,
and I agree with every word--
and that was so beautiful--
and there's her wisdom, her
toughness, her intelligence.
The thing I wanted to underscore
is something you said,
which is, her role
as a preacher's kid.
And Gwen's family was actually
foundational for the AME Church
in the United States.
And I think one of the
things that we will most
miss about Gwen is that
profound, persistent, stubborn
moral sense that she brought
to every aspect of her life.
Her church was the news
hour, and her congregation
remains faithful.
Secondly, I want to pay
tribute to Judy Woodruff.
Everybody knows how
brilliant she is,
what an extraordinary
journalist she is.
I once said of someone--
you know it showed me what
I thought of journalism--
this person's a journalist
and is really moral,
and then I thought
to myself, what
does that tell you about what
you think of journalists.
And Judy is just one of
the most warm-hearted,
thoughtful, other-directed,
welcoming people
I have ever met.
Now, as David
Brooks pointed out,
I am Catholic so I feel
guilt easily and deeply.
And, I got to say,
whenever I see Judy,
and I reflect on her
goodness and decency,
I feel even more guilty.
And I just do not
understand how someone
can make me feel so good
about life, and so guilty,
at the same time.
I love you Judy Woodruff.
I also want to pay tribute to
my sister Lucy and a Navy JAG
veteran who is in the audience
who would've killed me
if I had not paid tribute to two
people she so deeply admires,
Judy and Gwen.
I was wondering, listening, if
this panel should be relabeled
alternative veritas,
because that's
where we seem to be going.
And I want to say that it is
really good to be with Jonah.
I confess to a soft
spot for Jonah.
I met Jonah when he was
22 years old starting out
in journalism in Washington.
Now, I recently quoted
Jonah, in my column,
and I agreed with him--
which shows the times we are in.
It was a debate in the National
Review about nationalism
versus patriotism.
And I agreed with Jonah
that there was a difference
and that we should
prefer patriotism.
But after I wrote that I didn't
know who should feel worse
about this, Jonah or me.
I mean, praise from
a liberal fascist
could make him guilty
by association.
And you're watching him
get all this applause.
I am now predicting the
headline in Breitbart,
phony conservative sellout wins
applause from Harvard Radcliffe
liberals.
- The sad part is
that's not a bold bet.
- So I'm worried
about the Radcliffe
as to ruining Jonah's
career, but there's
a lot of room on the
liberal fascist side,
and we would welcome you.
I just want to make
a couple of points,
one of my favorite
memos from an editor
was a one-line memo
from an AP editor
that read, avoid
cliches like the plague.
And what I was contemplating
today, and what to talk about,
the cliche that came to
mind-- it's a great line
in the original, but
it's become a cliche--
this is the best of times
this is the worst of times.
And I think when we
think about journalism,
right now, that is exactly
correct about where we are,
right now.
This is the best of
times in the sense
that I don't think Americans
have as fully appreciated
the role of independent
journalism as they do now.
That is to say, a significant
group of Americans.
And I think, that as we see the
investigative work being done,
this amazing competition
among newspapers,
they are starting
to make movies again
about journalism where
the journalists are not
played by the people in
the bar scene in Star Wars.
I mean this is an
extraordinary moment.
So I think there
is an appreciation
for the role of journalism that
we haven't seen in a long time.
And yet, there is great division
over the role of journalism,
and, I think that, one, it
is genuinely disturbing--
what's even more disturbing
than that candidate slogged out
a reporter who asked
him a hard question--
is that the alibi
used by the candidate,
that was widely
accepted, was, it
was OK to slug him because
he was a liberal journalist,
and that really tells us
something about the divisions
we face now.
I'm not going to talk primarily
about opinion journalism
but I passionately agree
with something, God help me,
Jonah said.
Because, I think it's important
to defend the role of opinion
journalism, which is what I do,
and there's the famous Daniel
Patrick Moynihan
line, people are
entitled to their own
opinions, they're not
entitled to their own facts.
But I think there should
be a corollary, which
is, opinion journalism
that is not based on fact
is not journalism.
I'm going to focus primarily
on the rest of what
I have to say on journalism
broadly speaking,
but I really do think we need
a conversation in the world
of opinion journalism, because
there is a real danger now,
more than we have
seen in the past,
and I'm very anti-nostalgia.
But more than we have
seen in the past,
that fact is getting
lost more and more.
The John F. Kennedy
whom David referenced
gave an extraordinary
commencement speech at Yale.
By the way, in that
commencement speech
he said when he got
an honorary degree,
I have the best of both worlds,
a Harvard education, and a Yale
degree.
But he also said
something that is--
I have recently gone through
some old JFK speeches
because his 100th
birthday is on Monday--
and he spoke of those who
seek the comfort of opinion
without the
discomfort of thought.
And I thought, what
an extraordinary line
for our moment.
Cass Sunstein recently wrote
a very interesting book
on the new media world and
he cited John Stuart Mill's
aspiration for debate
in a democratic republic
it involved, Mills said,
"placing human beings
in contact with persons
dissimilar to themselves
and with modes of
thought and action
unlike those with
which we are familiar."
And as Sunstein noted,
we live in a time
when it is far easier
than ever, I think,
partly because of the way we
live and organize our lives,
we tend to live more with people
we agree with than we used to,
partly because of technology.
And I think it's important
when we think about technology,
that technology makes everything
more efficient, which includes
both the spreading of truth,
and the spreading of lies,
and the two can
happen, simultaneously.
But more than that, we can live
in our own information worlds.
And I just want to
salute a study that
was done by the Berkman Klein's
Center for Internet & Society,
here at Harvard, and MIT'S
Center for Civic Media.
They study 1.25 million
stories studied online,
between April 1st,
2015, and election day.
And they concluded
that, first, this
is a problem more on the
right end of politics
and on the left end of
politics, and that, liberals
tend to consume a larger
mix of media that includes
old fashioned media,
whereas a significant group
of conservatives consume
primarily, or almost entirely,
conservative media.
Now, Jonah might argue that's
because all the regular media
are liberal, but I
think that has actually
led to some real
problems on the right,
by rejecting any
sources that aren't
conservative on their face.
This study concluded that
a right wing media network
anchored around
Breitbart developed
as a distinct and
insulated media system
using social media as
a backbone to transmit
a hyper-partisan
perspective to the world.
This pro-Trump
media sphere appears
to have not only been
successful in setting
the agenda for the
conservative media sphere,
but also strongly
influenced the broader media
agenda in particular
coverage of Hillary Clinton.
While concerns about political
and media polarization online
are longstanding, our study
suggests that polarization
was asymmetric.
Pro-Clinton
audiences were highly
attentive to traditional
media outlets which
continued to be the
most prominent outlets
across the public sphere.
That's good news.
Along with more
left-oriented online sites.
But pro-Trump audiences paid
the majority of their attention
to polarized outlets
that have developed
recently-- many of them only
since the 2008 election.
This study points
to a central truth
that we can't evade that, the
problem presented by Trump
is, not the creation of
broad general trends that
have nothing to
do with ideology,
it is not the product
of technology itself,
the loss of a
common conversation
is the result in
significant part
of new habits on the political
right but their habits
ingrained since the 1960s.
And the Harvard MIT study
underscored this by noting that
technology alone cannot be held
accountable but that technology
has enabled these developments.
I won't go into this study more.
But I think that one of the
issues we should discuss
is the asymmetric quality
of this conversation,
of this problem.
But also the problems that might
exist on my side of the ledger.
I just want to close
with two thoughts.
One is, from Vaclav
Havel, who said
that, when a truth is not given
complete freedom freedom is not
complete.
And in his powerful
essay on tyranny,
the historian Timothy
Snyder offered 20 lessons
that the 20th century had
to teach us at this moment,
and lesson 10 was at once
basic, and essential,
believe in truth.
He wrote that to abandon
facts is to abandon freedom.
If nothing is true, then
no one can criticize power.
You submit to tyranny
when you renounce
the difference between
what you want to hear,
and what is actually the case.
Thank you.
- Thank you, EJ Oh my gosh
we have so much to talk
about and so little time.
There have been two
references to it,
but I want to go back
to it but for a slightly
different reason.
So we all woke up this
morning to a headline,
"Gianforte Wins
Congressional Race One Day
After Assaulting a Reporter."
And so, putting aside the actual
act, where I want to dwell
is on the reporting of that.
And we had a situation wherein
there were eyewitnesses
to the actual event, and
the best eyewitnesses
were from Fox News,
it turned out,
and the reporters gave a
really clinical description
of what had happened.
And it was a description
in complete variance
with the description given
by the then candidates.
Press spokesmen and Fox News,
and its coverage of the event,
gave much more time and favor
to the press spokesman's
description of the event than to
their own reporter's accounts.
Which pretty much
underscored the reporter's
telling of the event, which
was that he had been assaulted
for asking a question.
And so, in this
conversation where
we're having and it's all
inspiring, and it's lofty,
don't lie, that will
solve our problems.
Facts, facts, facts.
More attention to the
scientific method.
How do we get there?
When it seems that it's going
to be very hard to extract
ourselves from this
dishonest relationship
we have with audiences
at the moment.
Which may be good for ratings,
but is very bad for democracy.
I think that's an example
of speaking to an audience
and telling them what
they might want to hear.
That's a comforting
version of what
happened, if you're of a
certain political stripe,
but it wasn't true.
So how do we get
from these ideals
to what's happening
on the ground,
in television or elsewhere?
- Can I just say, I think
traditional media have been,
and continue to be,
deeply attentive to fact.
I mean I don't think
it shocks us that Fox,
although it's going through a
kind of revolution, right now,
it's going to be
interesting to see
what Fox is five years from now
compared to what it is today,
but that Fox is primarily
an opinion outlet that
happens to have some real
good, decent, reporters working
for it.
And so, I guess,
fair and balanced
is the footage of the
event on the one side,
and the statement by
the Republican candidate
about the event that people
have just seen on the other.
I think that part
of the question
is, how people
consume their news,
and whether they are
even exposed to facts
that they disagree with.
Mark Zuckerberg
spoke here yesterday.
And the notion that
we all get news.
Fewer people go to the original
source, whether the New York
Times, The Washington
Post, or any other outlet,
or National Review,
for that matter,
and they are more exposed to
what their friends tell them,
or what they see on
Facebook and Twitter.
This system can be gamed
in ways that people aren't
even exposed to the
alternative view or a challenge
to a factually untrue
statement, and I
think that is one of
the problems we face.
On the other hand, I think
all traditional media
can do is to continually
seek larger audiences
and to insist over and over
again that the facts matter
and to apply that day
to day in what they do.
And I really do believe that
my colleagues, on the reporting
side, do exactly that.
- So I think the
answer to your question
has many parts, Ann Marie.
I think that's one of the
reasons it's challenging.
There's a part of the
answer that's about,
let's call it civic
education in K through 12,
and there's a part
of the answer that's
about how a massive business
conglomerate, like Fox
News and Murdoch's news
corps, changes course,
and that's just one example.
There might be other examples
we point to that perhaps we
think should change course.
And there are two very
different questions.
And so I think one
of the challenges
has always sort of figuring out
where to focus one's energy.
If one focuses on the K through
12 part of the conversation,
it matters that one of
the most painful victims
of our polarization has been
social studies education.
So I don't know how
clear people are on that.
But when the National
Governors Association
try to develop the Common
Core State Standards
they aspire to have standards
and three areas math
and science, English language
arts, and social studies.
And they achieved the
first two of those--
whatever you think of the
standards of testing--
is the case that if you have
them you teach in those areas.
And so there has been
measurable significant declines
of time in school on social
studies for the last 15 years.
Going back even before the
Common Core State's standard
so that no child left
behind And the reason
they didn't achieve
the third standards,
was precisely
because, as a society
we couldn't agree on how
American history should
be taught.
Is it a triumphal story of
the Americans continuously
breaking through one frontier
barrier after another
and achieving greatness?
Or is it a story
that is dragged down
by the histories of slavery, and
genocide of Native Americans,
and so forth?
There is a way to tell both
parts of the story together.
We have not found a way
to do that, politically.
And so, paradoxically,
rebuilding civic education such
that young people can
have the tools to process
the media, to be the kind of
market for high quality media
that we need, actually
requires the grown ups--
all of us-- to be able
to tell a shared history
and recommit to standards
in education in this area.
- I actually agree
with all of that.
Civilization is a verb.
Hannah Arendt had this
great line she said,
every generation
western civilization
is invaded by barbarians,
we call them children.
And the factory
preset of humanity
is always poverty and
ignorance, and the children
you raise up as a society
become the replacement
for your civilization.
If you don't care about
it, if you don't teach them
how to be good citizens, they're
not going to be good citizens
and they're not going
to want the things
that good citizens want.
I want to push back a little
bit on the Fox News point,
in part, because I am a Fox
News contributor, and, in part,
because I think Fox News
is wildly misunderstood
by a lot of people.
I agree with EJ
entirely, Fox News
is going through quite
a transition right now,
and I'm not happy at all.
I was a very, very sharp
critic of some of the stuff
that Sean Hannity has been
doing the last couple of weeks.
But, first of all, EJ
Is right, the news side
is actually full of a lot of
really excellent reporters,
many, many of whom
are not conservative.
They're just reporters,
and this is the best job,
this is that the
job they wanted.
They like what they do.
They like the freedom
that they have.
And but what also people
have never understood
is that Fox has
never been nearly as
right wing as a lot of people--
a lot of its critics-- think
it is.
It's always been more
populous than right wing.
It has always worked on
the assumption-- well,
an executive there once showed
me what the market for Fox News
was, and he put his left
hand over the eastern border
of California, and his right
hand over the western trim
of New York City, and said,
all this stuff in the middle,
that's our market.
And Fox News works from
a certain assumption,
in terms of-- not
talking about the news
part, per se-- but the
gestalt of the network,
which is that this is a good
country, that American people
are good people, that the
military may make mistakes
but it's something to be honored
and respected, that the police
may make mistakes,
there may be bad apples,
but there's people who should
be honored and respected.
That this was a good and
decent country and that
it shouldn't be run down.
Now, you may think that it's
sort of invidious for me
to make this point,
and that somehow it's
wrong to suggest that the
mainstream media doesn't
agree with that.
But that is a
widespread-- and I will
argue-- very
understandable perception
about a lot of the way
the mainstream media has
operated for the last 40 years.
And just on this sort
of balance thing.
Look, first of all, just
to bolster Daniel's point
a little bit, my favorite
New Yorker cartoon
has two dogs sitting,
drinking Martinis
in a bar in New York
in pinstriped suits.
And one dog says
to the other dog,
"You know, it's not good
enough that dogs succeed.
Cats must also fail."
And we are living as a culture--
not just the media
culture, but as
a culture-- in a
moment where what
I call "ecstatic
schadenfreude" runs rampant.
Where it's not just that the
news has to help my side.
It has to make you
feel bad, right?
And that's what the arguments
on Twitter are all about.
But the idea that somehow that
the mainstream media, the media
that EJ is touting, doesn't
have any double standards
of its own, I just think
is just flatly wrong.
And I could argue
about it for hours.
But I'll just give one
example from this week.
It was reported this week
that the FISA courts had
to chastise brutally the
Obama administration for lying
to them, for misleading them
while they were scooping up
vast amounts of private
data in this country.
One out of 20 emails in
this country was scooped up.
And The New York Times,
the Washington Post,
the major news networks,
none of them covered this.
If this had happened on
George W Bush's watch,
this would have been a
front-page, five-alarm story
about the intrusion on
our civil liberties.
And yet, it was only
covered on broadcast
on a network by Fox News,
at least as of last night.
And it's only been covered in
a handful of other outlets,
because it's a story
that's bad for Obama,
and sort of
distracting from Trump.
And this kind of thing
happens a vast amount
more than I think a lot of
people in the mainstream media
want to credit.
And it's noticed by
people on the right.
And when people on the right--
and I don't even mean
people on the right,
I mean normal Americans who make
up a big chunk of this country,
and when they see
these double standards,
it makes them lose faith
and confidence in the media.
And that makes it
all the more hard
for the media to do its job,
which is to get the truth out
to everybody.
- I want to ask A'Lelia--
I want to ask her a
question about opinion news.
And I do with some trepidation,
when I have three people who
write columns on this podium.
One observation is that in your
lifetime as a news executive,
we experienced
this proliferation
of opinion-based journalism.
And there is now a lot of
news coverage, quote, unquote,
"news coverage" that's a lot
of people sitting arrayed
like this, arguing
their differing
political perspectives on
a news subject of the day,
versus kind of on-the-ground
reporting, which
seem to be in short
supply, for instance,
in coverage of the Trump
campaign during the election,
which led to our kind of failure
to understand what was really
happening with those voters.
I'm wondering as somebody
who spent her career making
decisions about what was covered
for two of the major networks,
if you can pinpoint sort of
a moment in the evolution
of television journalism
and tell us what you think--
how you think that's worked out.
- Well, you know, I
just had a flashback.
And this was before
Fox News, when
Brit Hume was working at ABC.
It's a story I've never told.
But I just remember this
when Lani Guinier was--
because I knew Lani
from Radcliffe.
When she was
nominated, I remember
Brit going on the 320, which
was our internal intercom,
talking about Lani,
and describing a person
that I totally didn't know.
But this was the narrative that
was coming from the right wing.
And that, for me, was
one of the moments.
And then Brit, eventually,
was at Fox News.
But if there is a moment,
that would be a moment
when I realized everyone
is not necessarily
trying to tell exactly the
story, exactly the truth,
that there is a perspective
and a demonization.
And I guess it's that
demonization that
was a turning point for me.
- I want to integrate some
of the questions we're
getting from the audience,
which are terrific.
And one of them focuses on the
interest currently in leaking.
And the question is, is it a
public service or a scourge?
And how do you assess the
ethics of a leak or of a leaker?
I think we've experienced leaks
in the past week that have both
been--
we've had two different
classes of leaks.
We've had the leaks
to journalists.
And then we've had,
of course, the leaks
from the oval about security
issues in conversations
with other countries.
But let's focus on the
journalistic half of that.
Are they good or
bad for democracy?
The president says
that they're bad.
EJ?
- Well, I'm very pro-leak.
Just, you know, I--
- Would you like to
give your phone number?
- I'm sorry?
Yeah.
No, but I mean, let's be candid.
When people--
anybody in politics
who sees a leak that hurts
their side of politics
regardless of where they
stand might sometimes
get angry about the
leak, and say, aha,
this is a motivated leak.
And I think the first thing that
matters is, is the leak true?
And that during the
McCarthy period,
there were things that
leaked that weren't true.
And so I think the test number
one is, is the leak true?
Test number two is,
is there something
in this leak that genuinely
endangers national security?
That's a fair question to ask.
If you leak military plans
in advance of something
the military is
going to do, it is
legitimate to say, no,
that's not something
that should be leaked.
I had a personal experience
of this when I was in Lebanon.
And a man called
William Buckley--
no relation to Bill Buckley--
was kidnapped.
And we covered this story.
And we journalists, all
looked at his resume.
And you could just
tell the guy was CIA.
But none of us reported this.
And we didn't report it because
this guy was in trouble enough.
We saw no reason to do that.
Unfortunately, for Mr.
Buckley, the kidnappers
knew that, because the
Iranians had discovered it
when they occupied the
US embassy in Iran.
And it put together--
taken all the shredded memos
and put them back together.
But none of us-- all of us
felt a sense of responsibility.
We're not going to sort of write
about this aspect of the guy's
life.
We reported what he
had done in the world,
but we didn't say that.
But, you know, obviously this
comes from a point of view
that does see the Trump
administration as potentially
very dangerous to our country.
There are many
different ways in which
a free Republic, a free
Democratic Republic,
can fight back against
abuses in government.
And one is the courts.
One is the electoral system.
One is free speech
through argument.
But one of them is the actions
of civil servants, people
who work for the government,
interacting with the media
to report on things
that they believe either
undermine the official story,
show the official story
as a lie, or put into public
discussion information
that the press and
the leaker believe is
in the public interest to do.
So to me, what Trump
is doing-- and it's
exactly what Richard Nixon did
in Watergate, although I think
all comparisons of Trump to
Nixon are unfair to Nixon,
but that's for another day.
I really do.
I could actually make that case.
I think they are largely
using this leak business
as a distraction to push the
story in a different direction.
- I've been obsessed in
recent months with lying.
And we focused a lot of
it on the White House.
But I just started asking
reporters in my everyday life,
tell me the first time you
were lied to for a story.
And we all have a
story about that.
And those experiences
form us deeply,
and I think contribute to
this kind of skeptical stance,
sometimes cynical, that you
see in a lot of journalists.
But what was
remarkable to me was
the line that occurs at
all levels in journalism.
Man-on-the-street interviews,
where somebody I talked to had
interviewed somebody who gave
her his boss's name instead
of his own, because he thought
it would be funny to see that
in the paper, on up through
conversations with Michael
Resendez at the Boston
Globe about being lied
to by the cardinal about sexual
abuse among Catholic priests
in Boston.
And I've written
about this recently,
but I'm reminded to
mention it, because one
of the questions
from the audience is,
should elected officials be
more accountable for facts
and for lies, for
stories that they invoke?
Is it different?
Should we have different
expectations from them
than we do from journalists?
One of my biases
is that we don't
do a good enough job of
explaining when we're lied to.
We kind of absorb it, and
try to ferret out the truth.
And then when we
make a mistake, it
looks like a journalistic fault.
But how do we balance that?
And how do we manage it from
a public official perspective?
- Can I open with just
one funny story that's
not for me, but from my friend,
Alison Mitchell, a great New
York Times journalist.
And she was interviewing the
speaker of the New York State
Assembly many, many years ago.
And she asked him a
very direct question.
And he looks at her straight
in the face and says,
"On the record, yes.
Off the record, no."
And Allison just
threw down her pen
and said, what the hell am
I supposed to do with that?
So I just can't resist
passing that on.
I'll let someone take it.
It's a very serious question.
- It's a day-in and
day-out, I think,
experience for most journalists.
- Yeah, one of the reasons
why I am not reporting--
I've done some reporting.
I had to go around.
But it's mostly sort of my
gimlet eye kind of stuff
rather than day-to-day
political reporting.
And politicians
call me all the time
and all that kind of thing.
But one of reasons why I don't
do reporting is I cannot stand
being lied to.
It just-- it makes me feel
like you think I'm an idiot.
And I also, because
I like arguments,
I can't listen to
people I think are
saying really stupid things,
and say, oh, that's interesting.
Oh, tell me more.
And some people have
that gift that they can--
and I don't denigrate
them for it.
Some of these people are
very good friends of mine.
They can sit there, and they'll
let people hang themselves
in front of them.
And I'm not good at that.
I just want to brawl.
William Rusher was the longtime
publisher of National Review.
He always used to pull over
the new kids at the magazine,
and he would say, look, I need
to explain something to you.
Politicians will
always disappoint you.
And the point was, particularly
for young ideological and
idealistic kids at
National Review,
is that politicians
are human beings.
Their incentive
structure is different.
They are set up to do-- to win
elections and to be popular.
And this is true of people
on the left or on the right.
It doesn't matter.
It's that the politicians are
human beings that journalists
want to either build
up or tear down,
the people want to
build up or tear down.
At the end of the
day, they're just
still made from the same
crooked timber of humanity
as everybody else.
I agree entirely that we should
have more expectations of them
not to lie.
But I also think
that bears shouldn't
use our national
forests as toilets.
Politicians will lie because
that is what they do.
- Danielle, from a--
I mean, you spent a lot of
time thinking and talking
and researching ethics.
What is the ethical
arrangement or relationship
between reporters and sources?
- Thanks, I'm going to put it
in a slightly different way,
if you don't mind,
which is to say
I think one has to put the issue
of the problem of legitimacy,
institutional legitimacy,
into the conversation as well.
So that is, lies undermine
the credibility and authority
and ultimately legitimacy of
any important institution.
So the leaks from civil servants
are a form of whistle blowing.
And that's because
they don't see
the legitimacy of the process
that they're working in.
The difficult thing then
is you sort of develop
a culture of leaks.
And so The New York
Times publication
of the Manchester material,
I think was a mistake.
I don't think that
there was anything
of public value in
that publication.
But I think that the culture
of expectation of leaking
has now extended
beyond places where
there is a problem with the
legitimacy in the process.
That is, there's
no reason to think
that the British process is
illegitimate and won't, as
appropriate, be transparent
about what they're learning.
No reason to think that.
And so therefore, I
think that was a mistake.
But so the reason I'm trying to
put this concept of legitimacy
together here with the
sort of issue of lying
is because I think one of the
things that we've been living
through is that a
lot of institutions
could protect their legitimacy
through secrecy, that
is through non-disclosure in
the pre-internet world, which
is not-- it's the
lie by omission,
not a lie by commission.
All right?
You can't keep things
secret anymore.
And so the first instinct when
that protective possibility
disappeared was to move
from the lie by omission,
as in the case of
the Catholic church,
to the lie by commission.
So in that regard,
I think, actually,
one of the core problems
has to do with leadership,
and how we teach
leadership, and how
we teach people to
think about protecting
their own organization
in conditions
of maximal transparency.
And I think that's actually
a very fundamental change
in people's basic habits
of self-protection.
So weirdly enough, I
actually think, in some ways,
we need to insist on
truth and hold people
accountable for lies,
and the electorate
holds elected officials
accountable for lies.
We need to hold people
accountable there.
But I actually think
we have to help
people rethink self-protection.
Because it's that, the
desire for self-protection,
even in conditions of
maximal transparency,
that is leading people into
corrupt forms of behavior.
And I think our anti-corruption
efforts needs to focus there.
- We have very little time left.
And I want to ask you all to
give me a very short answer
to a very big question.
I was thinking when A'Lelia
mentioned the 1984 Jesse
Jackson campaign, and she
talked about how this was really
a coming of age for a
lot of black journalists
and an entry into
political reporting
for a lot of black journalists--
these moments that come
and they change forever kind of
the trajectory of the industry,
right?
And so I guess the question is
inspired by that and by someone
in the audience, who says,
how will the media industry
change in the next decade?
I'd like to hand each of you a
crystal ball or a magic wand.
You can take whichever.
And tell us very briefly, when
another panel is assembled here
under Dean Cohen
some years from now,
and they're debating
something else
but looking back at this
moment, what will we
say changed about
journalism and fact-seeking
as a result of this period?
EJ?
- Oh, thanks a lot for--
[LAUGHTER]
This will just give me
a chance to piggyback
on the other point you made,
which is I was sitting here
racking my brain.
I do not remember being directly
lied to very much face to face.
I remember far more people
putting spin on events,
giving partial
versions of events.
And I actually think
this moment really
is different in kind in
terms of outright lying
that we are seeing,
that it doesn't mean
other politicians haven't lied.
I think there is a
kind of disrespect
for truth all together
that's deeper, which
is why I'll go-- that's how
I'll lead into my answer
to your question.
I think that we'll
remember this time
as a time of enormous
technological change, which
is forcing everyone to find
new ways to find audiences.
It's a time of enormous
economic change, where
what we call
traditional journalism
is beginning again,
but very slowly,
to find its footing to
finance a public good.
We used to finance the
public good of journalism
through monopoly profits
that newspapers made.
Those monopoly profits
are gone, and so now we're
trying to figure out how do
you finance this public good.
I think that is going to
be very, very important.
And I'll just close with
this, that I think that the--
I truly believe the Trump period
presents fundamental problems
to our attitudes toward
both liberty and equality,
to pick up Daniel's point.
And that how we cope-- how
people stood on this, how they
battled, and how they tried to
tell the American people what
was going on, people
are going to be judged
by how they behaved
in this period,
more than in other periods
of American history.
- Thank you.
A'Lelia?
- So, I mean, I think we are
at an existential moment.
I think we were probably lulled
over the last eight years
into thinking that the
country could come together.
I don't mean post-racially,
but a different optimism.
I think this is
disruptive right now.
I think that 20 years from
now, 50 years from now,
this will be seen
as an aberration.
At least, I hope it will.
I hope it doesn't--
that we are not going in a
direction from which we cannot
come back.
But I think it is
the responsibility--
people will ask, where were
you on the side of history?
I mean, one of my journalism
classes, Fred Friendly
was my journalism professor.
And he had been at CBS
during the McCarthy
hearings with Edward R Murrow.
And I think that we
will look back and say,
what were those hearings like?
Where were people?
How did they report?
What were the elected
officials doing?
- Danielle.
- I'll take the magic wand.
I've got five waves,
slightly crazy.
Here we go.
End the war on drugs,
reduce expenditures
on criminal justice,
reinvest in education,
including public
universities, work our way
through our polarization to
enough of a shared narrative
to rebuild civic
education and thereby
create a market for
the PBS News Hour.
- And let it never be said
that Radcliffe did not
give the last word
to a conservative.
- The prophecies are true.
You know, I've spent the last
two years, pretty bad two
years, and I've
come to define hope
as that brief pause
between kicks to the groin.
And so I'm tempted
just to say, buy gold.
But a couple of
scattershot points.
One, a lot of us are
still in the grips
of nostalgia about a
certain parentheses
in American history, about this
idea of objective national news
that really comes basically
out of the 1930s and 1940s
and then really with
the rise of television.
If you go back, and you read the
coverage of the Lincoln-Douglas
debates between the Republican
papers and the Democratic
papers, and in the
Republican version, Lincoln--
Douglas was reduced to a
quivering puddle of jello
as he could not
withstand the blinding
heat of Lincoln's oratory.
And then the democratic
papers were, like, 12 men
had to restrain Lincoln.
So incensed was he to lose
the argument so resoundingly.
And what I would
love to see is--
not a return to that,
but a return to the idea
that the most important
media in people's lives
is generated closer to
home, that comes out
of the organic community
in which they live,
that covers the world that
they actually live in.
I'm very big believer in
pushing down as much democracy
to the lowest level possible.
Because that's how
it is the best way
to maximize the happiness
of the most people.
And the other only
last point I'll make,
is that the written
word ain't going away.
They keep pronouncing it dead.
And yet it endures.
And the secret, as any
good television producer
will tell you, is that
the written word still
drives television.
Because where people learn
about what's going on
is from newspapers
and magazines,
and now from screens,
but someone still
had to write it down first.
And that is a glorious and
wonderful thing, because it
might keep me employed.
- Thank you.
And please, just join
me again in thanking
all of our panelists--
EJ, A'Lelia,
Danielle, and Jonah.
Thanks so much.
- So let me add my thanks to
the panelists for really a very
thoughtful and
terrific conversation,
and to the audience for
your great questions,
and, again, to Ann Marie for
guiding the discussion so
expertly.